you know i think
austin and ali decided to do like an
official duo situation i'm not sure if
they would be engaged yet
i just got a call to do the hair and
makeup for the royal wedding
for 50
dollars
it's like a glass slipper but money
laura it's crazy because i feel like the
royal treatment is just like this
perfect tornado of all of your skills
you're starring in it you're producing
it you have two songs in the movie let's
talk about your music like this is first
of all congratulations girl you're
absolutely killing it are you aware
there's a pandemic going on like it's
okay to like wear sweatpants
i am very grateful with everything
that's happening and with already the
response about the film i mean fans are
so excited which just brings so much joy
to me dance with you the song that i
wrote for the film that's in the end
title scene and the last scene and the
entire credits um you know it has done
the best for an independent artist it's
hard being an independent artist and it
has done absurdly well for me um
which is
just i'm still overwhelmed by that and
then the other song i have in the movie
that's coming out the same day as the
royal treatment um is called worst kind
of hurt and that song i wrote for myself
i did not write for the movie i'm going
through a breakup and so i was very much
inspired by that most people who aren't
following the press i mean they won't
even know necessarily that it's laura
singing because the songs just fit and i
think they make sense they work
perfectly with the genre i can see why
they got chosen and i think they make
perfect sense for the film laura
congratulations a producer on the film
wearing so many different hats
eventually hoping to get you into tiara
what was it like kind of having that
power behind the scenes and how did that
change the way you approach the film
honestly i love being a producer as an
actor you just don't have that same
control over how a movie turns out or a
project turns out or whatever i am such
a control freak that i am very much like
i want to be a part of every single
aspect and one of the aspects that i am
so proud that i was a part of not to
toot my own horn but i do have an eye
for casting and i kind of was the first
one to say nina for prince thomas i was
like we were talking about casting and
nino was the one who was like on top of
my list welcome to levadia
may i introduce prince thomas i'm very
grateful that i had the opportunity to
work with laura and her family her mom
and her sister also being producers on
the film and netflix for the first time
i honestly just couldn't be more happy
with the overall process how everything
went i do love mina going from prince
ali to prince thomas you play these
swoon-worthy guys very very well laura
what is it about mina that you think
makes such a great leading man i love
this this is just a compliment nina i
just want to make mean as uncomfortable
as possible nina though is truly such a
charming person he just has this
charisma about him that's just so
natural and part of himself and i think
one of my favorite things about mina as
well is nina you're so smart like you
are just so so intelligent and so smart
and i think that intelligence plus that
charisma just comes across and it just
it makes you just can't take your eyes
off this man you're like meena you were
giving me the look what look this look
we are in the day and age of reboots and
reunions that's why i was so excited for
the royal treatment because this is
something brand new this isn't an
adaptation but i do need to check in
with you guys about some of your most
beloved past roles and do a little roll
call for what could be coming up next
i'm lena
my favorite straight to video disney
movie of all time was aladdin return of
jafar
it is
incredible
would you ever be down for an aladdin
sequel have there been rumblings yeah
i'd for sure be down i'd be down for a
royal treatment sequel too so uh just
putting that out there and there are
rumblings they're still working on it um
you know it's taken a while i think
they've gone through a few different
iterations of what the story would be
they don't want to follow the straight
to vhs uh story lines so it'll be a
brand new storyline if it does happen
and we've all got our fingers crossed
that it'll happen so we'll just have to
wait and see i'm also keeping my fingers
crossed that we could see you show up on
the mandalorian or some kind of star
wars iteration because the fan outcry to
see you play the beloved book character
of ezra bridger is so intense are you
aware of this mina i'm aware i'm on
twitter so i see things uh you know i
appreciate the fan response i have
incredible fans that you know kind of
always push me to play different things
and i'd love to be part of the star wars
universe i'd also just love to be a lot
of other different universes out there
so uh you know uh what whatever's in the
stars
will happen you know so we'll see we'll
see what happens that was good and like
completely yeah on a completely
different note have you talked to john
favreau at all recently maybe i haven't
i'd love to meet john haven't spoken to
john uh haven't met him no well i'm
keeping my fingers crossed on that laura
we gotta talk about the show that first
bonded us when you think about austin
and ally what do you think ali is up to
today well that's what's tough right
because we ended our season or we ended
our series with like 30 years flash
forward of wherever we'd be in 30 years
but there was obviously a middle ground
of like what they would do i think ally
would be going on tour
i think she would have won a few grammys
at this point
austin and ali decided to do like an
official duo situation so i'm curious if
they only would do touring together if
they did touring separately i'm not sure
if they would be engaged yet i feel like
they were maybe they would take their
time i don't know i don't know maybe
maybe they don't get engaged and have a
short engagement that get married in
their 30s who knows okay who knows i
think there's a lot of a lot of possible
such motions here i've got to know when
was the last time you talked to ross if
disney channel wanted to do some type of
an adult reboot what do you think a
hundred somebody done i just saw ross
for his show his band the driver error
was at the fonda
and i went with a couple friends of mine
i can't believe it's been 10 years since
the first episode aired that's we
celebrated that in december and that has
made me feel quite old um but also
the seeing how fans are still so excited
about and still love it so much um we
have new fans who are watching on disney
plus i know for a fact we all four would
be down